oh je was geht hier ist euer max und
herzlich willkommen zur heutigen folge
minecraft nero ich gehe direkt auf dem
server und ja diesmal ist kommen nicht
dabei der muss ja aussetzen
dafür kommt insofern ich heute nicht
sterbe die nächste folge wieder direkt
mit komme ich werde das probieren ein
bisschen auf wird schießen und hand zu
gehen bzw einfach produktiv zu sein
hauptziel ist es dass ich ein paar
diamanten finde absolut muss das heute
mein hauptziel sein
obama hat in seiner letzten folge die
durfte er bei ihm ein bisschen länger
gehen da er das frau spielen durfte wo
ich ihn gerettet habe hat er die
schlucht wiedergefunden
ich probiere es jetzt auch weil die
schlucht war eigentlich richtig richtig
gut und dias zu finden war einfach
mitten drin gelegen
und das kommt wie so bekannt vor hier
teilweise deshalb denken wir die kann
nicht weit sein
gomez ja auch wieder grund deshalb kann
sich wirklich nicht weit sein aber es
macht mich gerade ein bisschen verrückt
auch dass ich in der letzten folge die
schlucht einfach nicht gefunden habe was
irgendwie ein bisschen ärgerlich so
daneben gab es wieder irgendeinen update
bist du es gerade gehört habe leute das
ist ein clown dann für diejenigen die
sich mit dem motto pack auskennen die
clowns sind böse und ziemlich stark
vor wo ist das viel ich meine ich würde
ihn gerne bekämpfen
das macht mich verrückt ich würde gerne
bekämpfen damit ich eine chance habe
diese clown waffe zu bekommen
die hat nur der klaren selbst glaubt
gott nacht schon wieder das mod pekin
kratz irgendwie echt an meinen nerven so
ein bisschen weiß halt irgendwie mega
mega gefährlich ist also du kannst
einfach absolut nicht einschätzen was
als nächstes passiert und vor allem
kannst du nicht deine höhle wieder
finden und bis davon ziemlich genervt so
kann schon schön ist hier oben
vielleicht irgendwas sagt hier ist
nochmal einmal die bauen wir steine in
die wege so ok hier sind fackeln
vermutlich von mir selbst vorkommen dass
solch ein fach austritt main gehen das
wäre natürlich nicht so spannend für
euch
die hier ein bisschen zu erforschen aber
ich glaube mal dass das wahrscheinlich
effektiver ist das wenn ich jetzt hier
ein bisschen rum laufe einfach nur und
ich hab mir sowieso gut gedacht dass ich
so ein bisschen die produktivitäts
schiene fahren möchte zumindest
anfänglich hier ein projekt
ok dann machen wir das jetzt einfach mal
so ich mich aber ob die höhe unter bauen
ja mach ich am besten so zack zack zack
zack
ich liebe diesen diesem simplen mord
dass die fackeln leuchten wenn man so in
der hand in der hand hat finde ich
absolut cool irgendwie weil es so
praktisch ist dann musst du mir jedes
mal wieder eine fackel platzieren wenn
irgendwie durch eine höhle läuft ich bin
nicht sicher ob das auch als ausleuchten
richtig zählt so das hat keine mops
gespannt werden
aber so oder so ist auf jeden fall eine
richtig gute sache wie ich finde ich
hoffe einfach dass mich hier keine üble
überraschung erwarten wenn ich mich hier
unterbau in form von dungeons oder sowas
wie irgendwelche jobs drin sind wo da
war zum beispiel leute auch das ist eine
überraschung aber ich probiere der zu
umgehen
aber natürlich wo lara ist sagt man ja
auch wenn alter minecraft spruch
gibt es auch hier kennt ihr das ich
glaub's schwimmt halbe stadt stimmt gar
nicht
aber irgendwie sagt man es doch schon
immer aber ist halt nicht mehr irgendein
richtiger lage sehr viel sondern sein
quelle wie einfach mittendrin
es sei denn hier kommt jetzt der see
weiter komm schon jetzt bitte lass mich
nicht umsonst hier mein leben riskieren
ja leute perfekt das nenne ich mal glück
bzw timing ich sag's so lassen wir nicht
umsonst machen und was sehen wir hier
verdammte diamanten leute ok sehr gut
okay da müssen wir aufpassen
mit der lara die hier zu runter zu
fließen droht so sehr sehr gut platte
diaz haben wir gefunden und das war es
auch wirklich jede jede menge glück auch
in der letzten folge mit patrick schon
dass wir welche gefunden haben aber ja
das bestätigt irgendwie diese diese alte
minecraft legende wo wir sind
dollar was sind ist auch dir ihr wisst
was ich meine
ich glaub ich hatte einfach mal die
klappe damit ist uns allen gefallen
getan so
ok irgendwie angst dass hier noch
überreste sind die mir das leben schwer
machen
das scheint relativ tief zu sanieren
aber es sind anscheinend nur zwei diaz
ich brauchte aber auch für eine sache
die ich kräften wollte noch die erst gar
nicht was wahr ich hab's mir hier
notiert für gut deshalb was explodiert
leute ihr habt es auch kaffee tee rücken
runter trifft man aber sein leben ist
nicht gott da ist gerade was explodiert
und ich brauchte noch für den weg bleibt
ob die us für ja die erste wie soll ich
sagen möglichkeit zu zaubern ich glaube
ich hab's ja in der letzten folge schon
ein bisschen erklärt beziehungsweise
angesprochen dass man um sein altar
quasi seinen blut netzwerk so
funktioniert das ganze
man opfert anfänglich sein blut später
dann auch das von monstern und so weiter
um sich dann ob ich halte man was einmal
bereit und sich dann hier vorteil zu
verschaffen wie zum beispiel fliegen und
so weiter und so fort ist es einiges
möglich es gibt zum beispiel auf sauber
die 12 durchgehend ermöglichen und all
diese energie die benötigt wird um zu
fliegen und so weiter und so fort wird
aus dem blut netzwerk gespeist
und deshalb hat auch blut alltag bzw der
name an sich bleibt magic so okay es ist
auch schon meine erste pigs kaputt
gegangen aber diesmal war ich nicht so
dumm und habe holz dabei das kann ich
direkt umsetzen wenn ich mir erstmal ein
ofen gemacht habe und neues eisen
gebraten hab dann schauen ist eine zeit
schon mal um love is here nur das
brauche ich erstmal nicht so wirklich
er ist dass hier noch gleich das erz bzw
wie gut ist es wartet hier das schwarze
ist es gar nicht
hier ist es rooney um kann man damit
roomster machen das würde sinn machen
irgendwie juni um st ja und damit kann
man dann was machen aber ich glaube so
die richtung funktioniert nadine auf
items nicht sowie kann was kann man
machen sondern nur wenn man weiß was man
will wie man es macht ich hoffe ihr
versteht nicht rein hier mit zwei diaz
haben wir gefunden würde es fürs erste
auch mal tun aber es wäre natürlich
etwas wenig sage ich mal
als ergebnis von der ganzen folge
deshalb suchen wir noch weiter
vielleicht können wir am ende noch
irgendwie hoch überirdisch gehen es ist
ja auch gar schon wieder nacht insofern
ist sowieso sinnlos wenn wir uns
irgendwie an der oberfläche bewegen
gerade und wir können dann ja wenn es
wieder tag ist eventuell nach oben
zurückkehren um uns dann letztendlich
den
applus zu machen denn wie heißt er noch
gleich anti atlas richtig so
entschuldigt dass ich ab und zu mal rust
ich bin irgendwie seit gut einem monat
oder so krank und ich weiß nicht die
leute die auch jetzt die jetzt nicht
unbedingt neu hinzugekommen sind sondern
meine video schon länger schauen ich bin
richtig motiviert ich glaube ihr merkt
dass auch ich habe einfach richtig viel
spaß dran weil ich mich auf so viel
damit auseinander gesetzt habe und die
chance und die nicht die chance hat
sondern die perspektive habe dass ich
einfach richtig gut hier sein kann
und einiges reißen kann und das alter
das lässt mich irgendwie so ein bisschen
verrückt werden wir alles explodiert
gottwald ich brenne erstmal löschen so
kein drama um nichts machen so das zeug
hier mal weg so gold ist immer wertvoll
ich brauche nämlich auch drei gold davon
habe ich ja schon zwei stück nutzen für
das für den sacrifice deutlich brauche
ich noch gold wer es mir dann später
möglich machen würde mein eigenes blut
zu spenden
ich werde dann gleich wenn ich irgendwie
mir so ein kleines grundstück oder so
abgesteckt habe mit komme in der
nächsten folge als ich lebe dann werde
ich mich darum kümmern dass ich mein
eigenes grundstück habe und dann auch
mein alltag dort aufstellen der erstmal
ja mittelpunkt der nächsten folge sein
wird bei der nächsten folge besser
gesagt
weil blatt magic ja ein relativ großes
thema ist so dann gehen wir wieder ein
bisschen weiter runter
ich dachte das wäre vielleicht ein
höhlensystem so viel glück hatten wir
dann doch nicht ein beziehungsweise mich
nicht beschweren
mit den dias so für sieben bis elf sind
ihr läuft die meisten ps und da streitet
man sich irgendwie auch noch ein
bisschen rum wo man denn jetzt
tatsächlich die meisten diamanten findet
ist das jetzt ein ernst dk willst du
mich also wie cool einfach zweimal die
us gefunden
snack vier sind mindestens fünf sind
mindestens 61 mindestens krass leute
krass krass krass dann hab ich jetzt
acht diaz läuft welches überhaupt noch
weitermachen weil das land mir
eigentlich fürs erste vielmehr die jetzt
brauche ich wirklich nicht ich glaube
fast ich decke mich hoch und versuchen
wir noch ein paar kühe zu snacken
engined andres over for now
das bedeutet wir können wieder gefahrlos
an die oberfläche zurückkehren
und nachdem wir hier unser die glück
hatten tue ich das auch mit freude
lieber hier zurück war eine fackel unten
lassen falls kreml runterfällt
aber dann brauche ich mich eigentlich
nicht auf zwei herunter bauen wenn ich
sowieso eine fackel nachstehen habe so
sei denn es ist lava aber bei lag man
eigentlich immer noch relativ schnell
reagieren
ich freue mich auch wirklich wenn cvp
beginnt wird glaube ich der wahnsinn der
da ist wieder die alte hülle da kann ich
ein bisschen zu fuß laufen und muss
nicht so viel
die hochbahn gott ich höre zombies
gehört sie wahrscheinlich auch
lasst mich in ruhe ich habe so eine gute
folge bisher
wo sind sie
das klingt wie so ein
pd denn man atmet und der irgendwie ein
problem mit seinem rachen hat weil der
so komische geräusche macht beim atmen
aber okay das war schon ein bisschen
nervig für euch dieses ständige fackel
an fackel aus waake anpacke aus das
heißt dass larry ist dann bestehe ich
möchte hier führe entschuldigen und
jetzt freue ich mich einfach wieder
weiter nach oben zur zack zack
die reisen mitnehmen kann er schon mal
nicht schaden
wir sind bei zwölf minuten extrem lies
was man hier schafft also ich bin
richtig euphorisiert was den verlauf
ja was den verlauf der letzten folgen
angeht sage ich mal
weil es einfach einfach lief okay da ist
schon die erde dann kommen wir an die
oberfläche ich probiere für mich und
dann wird vielleicht auch bekomme wenn
ich die nächste folge wieder mit ihm
aufnehmen
einfach mal ein bisschen leder zu
besorgen dass wir uns den anti atlas
machen
es nervt uns selbst so aber ich mache
das schon seit wochen
mir selbst fehlt es auch gar nicht auf
lediglich wenn ich dann meine eigene
aufnahme anschaue merklich alter höher
auf sie wussten es nervt so übertrieben
okay da ist das gras erde also das sind
wirklich um
ich bin auch relativ froh dass ich okay
dass ich erster gegner ist am ob kontakt
schola von dem wurde die liste folgen
ich bin relativ hoch
das team kann sich deportieren oder was
ein leck okay aber mit wissen rüstung
sind die gar nicht so gefährlich die
dinger es muss ich mal gucken dass ich
den weg in die stadt zurück finde
beziehungsweise einpacken
die stadt ist schon direkt hier was sie
sagen wollte ich bin recht froh dass ich
so viel essen am anfang wir sichern
konnte das war ja nicht verboten sondern
die anderen sind aber noch nicht auf die
idee gekommen das ist auf jeden fall
sehr nice dass ich mich darum nicht
sorgen kann
er muss braucht ja ich habe ja zumindest
auf dem schiff gibt es auch melonen man
sich mal zu dass sie mir hier die stadt
irgendwie mal screenshot dass ich dann
falls ich verloren gehen sollte
irgendwie mal nachgucken kann liegt auch
irgendwo komme ja eigentlich ich habe
mir gedacht komm platz für den german
noch mal ein schild neben dran
die letzte folge schon gedacht dass ich
das nicht gemacht habe ist ja unmöglich
das mache ich das hier mal
sehr gut komme kann ich dann schreiben
von scott schreiben wir einfach um auf
nummer sicher zu gehen dass kollege sehr
gut dann weiß glaube ich jeder bescheid
so der erste tote ist zu beklagen in
unseren reihen
was steht hier zum hafen ich weiß noch
gar nicht wo ich hin soll glaubt er weit
ist jetzt sowieso nicht so optimal für
kühe
ich habe noch fünf minuten zeit usa
black usa 90 herzen seht ihr ein ende
hat glaube ich 40 und klappen ende
werden macht bei weitem nicht so viel
schaden wie dieser wolf also ich bleibe
lieber mal auf den bäumen das sowieso
eine relativ sichere möglichkeit sich
fortzubewegen ist hinter mir nicht sehr
gut
ja jetzt wird's eng hallef mich an ich
gehe mal dass ich weil ich irgendwie die
hoffnung habe dass ich gute drops kriege
wenn ich die viecher töte und management
slice ach das ist ja gar nature das fing
das via twitter also natur und jetzt
haben wir natur melonen stücke bekommen
das ärgert mich hier dass wir an diesem
waldstück sind ich glaub ich kehre erst
mal in die stadt zurück und macht diese
die sachen die ich noch machen kann vom
blut eltern es nämlich den aber
unbesorgt wieder abbauen kann
das frage ich mich so ein bisschen
wieder irgendwie schiffe bekommen
wahrscheinlich weil ich irgendwie viel
gelaufen bin
wir gucken einfach mal wir brauchen hier
einen weg bleibt ob den machen wir indem
wir werden den ersten blut altersrenten
aber erstmal im blut eltern mit blut
befüllen und dafür brauchen wir den hier
leckere fische live also sozusagen das
messer der des opfers gold eisen glas
glas einfluss gab es doch hier direkt
perfekt wenn wir uns hier ein bisschen
erde 5 er sei schon gebraucht war für
spätere pläne auch noch insgesamt zwölf
glas dann komme ich mich jetzt mal drum
und da kommt schon das wasser verdammt
bisschen unschön auch dass ich das hier
mache aber ich weiß gar nicht genau in
welche richtung der fluss war so viel
habe ich jetzt 11 1 1 sand brauche ich
noch habe ich erst mal meinen ersten
glas bedarf gedeckt so nämlich auch den
sand hier und es habe ich zwölf leute
drauf da würde einfach sagen und das
fähig macht mir erst mal keine angst und
ich probieren zu erledigen op ein herz
schaden geht man schon relativ laute
tank teilte denkt aber wir haben
erledigt und ich habe gehofft auf
irgendwelche coolen drops
leider nicht der fall hier sugar kane
mit kroatien wieder angepflanzt deshalb
nehme ich mir erst mal alles mit was
kann ich wegwerfen als schaufel braucht
jetzt weniger so hier geht's auch kann
ich den angreifen ich glaube nicht an
gott 200 jahre verdammt alter mache ich
mir nicht draufgekommen ja dass das ist
so manche monster kann man erst
eingreifen wenn man eine bestimmte ein
bestimmtes level an heiligen spielens
hat und dann kannst du die partout nicht
gehen auch im game ort nicht du kannst
du nicht in die luft jagen mit tnt
bisher nicht irgendwie ihren kampf modus
aktiviert bekommen sind die nicht tot zu
kriegen und das mega es sind da kannst
du nichts anderes machen als einfach nur
rennen aber ich bin wirklich zufrieden
noch keinen tod zu beklagen
und ja jetzt wäre es einfach nur noch
super wenn wir kühlen finden dass
schafft mir glaube ich aber nicht mehr
ich werde es aber zurückkehren die stadt
und dann in der nächsten folge beginnen
wir direkt also unbedingt einschalten
mit dem segway fische live dann werden
wir unser erstes eigenes blut opfern um
uns ja mit der black magic zu beginnen
komisch ersatz dafür beendet jetzt die
folge hier ist eins diesmal kein 20
minuten zuerst mal was wir zehn sekunden
länger oder so das war's von heute haut
rein und bis zum nächsten mal
julius macht's gut